at the turn of the sixteenth century the
Ottoman Empire was exceptionally
powerful it had expanded deep into
southeastern Europe dominated the
eastern Mediterranean and had tremendous
influence in the Indian Ocean but one of
the questions that isn't asked too often
about the Ottoman Empire is why after
the discovery of the Americas did the
Ottomans make no attempt to colonize it
there are ultimately several reasons for
this and the first is simple geography
whilst the Ottomans dominated in their
local neighborhood breaking free of the
Mediterranean wasn't so easy the reason
was that they had to go through waters
controlled by the Arakanese Castilian
and Portuguese crowns who wouldn't have
been too happy at the idea of a Muslim
power competing with them in the new
world the ottomans did have access to
the Indian Ocean - and so could easily
have just gone around Africa right well
yes but the journey would have been
considerably longer and why do that when
you could just say at least and trade
with Asia which brings us to another
reason the Ottomans didn't need to sail
across the Atlantic
remember that the European powers sailed
west in order to avoid trading with and
through the Ottoman Empire thereby
enriching it the Ottomans could simply
trade with whomever they wanted because
they sat at the crossroads of three
continents furthermore the value of the
new world wasn't really known at this
point perhaps then the most that the
Ottomans could have gained would have
been to deny places like Spain or
Portugal colonies in the first place the
thing is the Ottomans had problems much
closer to home they had to contend with
the Habsburg monarchy to the north as
well as enemies to the south and the
East such as the Safavid Empire the idea
was floated that the Ottomans could
conquer all the way to Morocco and get
themselves an Atlantic coast from here
they would capture some of the west
coast of Africa before moving across the
Atlantic in depriving the Europeans of
future territories the discovery in
later colonization of the Americas
presented a problem for the Ottomans
they had recently sought to emulate
China and become a strictly law-based
hierarchical empire whose subjects would
own oil tea to an emperor the problem
now was the places like Spain and
Portugal had revolutionized what the
world was these states were proving that
sheer tenacity in a disregard for
established knowledge had its benefits -
in fact fear of failing to capitalize on
this new style of thinking was present
at the Ottoman corpus Alton's like
Suleiman the Magnificent were frankly
completely uninterested to him in his
successes these new developments weren't
seen as threatening the Ottoman position
to be fair the Mediterranean had always
been one of the most important trade
routes in world history the fact that
this would stop being the case because
of these new discoveries wasn't exactly
obvious at the time to summarize the
Ottoman Empire understood that the
discovery of the new world was a big
deal but didn't really see how it
affected them whilst the idea of the
Ottomans taking some of the new world
was floated they ultimately had their
own problems these problems were the
Safavids the Arabians the Hapsburgs are
now the Portuguese in the Indian Ocean
the sultan's of the Empire even the
great ones like Suleiman did not see how
these lands could endanger their
position and honestly how were they to
know that the discovery of the new world
would shift the center of power to the
west I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to all of these patrons you see
on screen for their generosity in
supporting the show and a particularly
special thanks to James Bissonnette
party-boy Co Ozark a flash Rob
Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael Reynolds
Thomas McGill Gustav Swan Winston
Haywood Skye Chappell the amusement park
Ives Adam Harvey
and lastly rafail